un dosel Esmeralda de árboles esencial
para combatir el cambio climático bajo
el mandato del expresidente Jair
bolsonaro la tala y la quema de la
amazonía se dispararon a un máximo en 15
años más de 41.000 kilómetros cuadrados
o el tamaño de Suiza se convirtieron en
humo pero ahora esa tendencia ascendente
de destrucción de los últimos cuatro
años ha cesado los datos preliminares
del gobierno brasileño muestran un
descenso del 41% solo en junio En
comparación con el año pasado
tenemos un resultado que a mi entender
merece ser celebrado ha habido una
reducción del 33% de la deforestación en
un período de seis meses seis meses
es algo alentador para nosotros Porque
hay una tendencia a la baja que sigue
los objetivos fijados por el gobierno
la selva amazónica absorbe el carbono
gracias a la fotosíntesis pero también
lo almacena suelo y en los árboles por
eso cuando se producen incendios como
este provocados en gran parte por el
hombre para despejar tierras para ganado
y la industria cárnica mundial estos
incendios liberan enormes cantidades de
CO2 a la atmósfera lo que los convierte
en uno de los principales contribuyentes
a la crisis climática Aunque 2600
kilómetros cuadrados de la amazonía se
convirtieron en humo entre enero y junio
de este año el gobierno de Lula dice que
la impunidad de los acaparamientos de
tierras los incendios provocados y el
escepticismo climático de bolsonaro se
han acabado estamos haciendo un esfuerzo
muy grande para poner nuestra casa en
orden Este es un trabajo que se está
haciendo en colaboración con la policía
federal la patrulla Federal de
carreteras la fuerza nacional y el
Ministerio de los pueblos indígenas con
la estación seca A punto de comenzar el
riesgo de incendios aumentando los
próximos meses seguirán siendo un reto
para el nuevo presidente que intentará
frenar la deforestación pero también la
extracción ilegal de oro y el robo de
tierras a los Indígenas